when acne attacks people suffer both
physically and emotionally
i'm alexis and i too have suffered from
acne but my journey ended with a cure
click the link below to start your skin
happy journey today
acne is a skin disease consisting of
blemishes that can occur
on your face neck chest
shoulders and back
acne is very common during the teen
years but it can affect you during
adulthood as well
to keep your hair and skin well
lubricated your body depends on
sebaceous glands
which sit just under your skin
these glands secrete an oily substance
called sebum
which coats your skin and hair to
prevent them from drying out
sebum travels up hair follicles and out
through your pores
onto the surface of your skin
your hair follicles routinely shed dead
skin cells
which sebum carries out of your body
when your body produces extra sebum and
dead skin cells
they can stick together and clog your
pores
resulting in skin blemishes
then bacteria that normally exist in
small amounts on your skin
can flourish in the sebum in the clogged
pore
leading to inflammation
depending on where the clog is located
and if you have inflammation
acne may appear as whiteheads which are
clogged follicles
closed off from the air blackheads
which are clogged follicles that turn a
darker color when the clog is exposed to
air
pustules commonly called pimples which
are inflamed follicles clogged with pus
or cysts which are larger painful pus
filled lumps going deep under the skin
you've seen how acne does its damage now
let's talk about how to treat it quickly
and effectively
as dr kenner says 80 percent of us get
acne at some point in our lives
100 of us hate it sadly there's no
single magic bullet to treat the 20
different subtypes of acne
instead to achieve the long-lasting cure
you're looking for you need to start
with a correct diagnosis
and then follow a personalized treatment
plan the good news is that dr kenner's
average patient is 50
improved by six weeks to start your skin
happy journey
click on the link below and receive a
free online diagnosis today
hormonal changes particularly a rise in
testosterone
can lead to sebum overproduction which
is why acne often occurs during the teen
years
however it can occur at any age other
factors contributing to the development
of acne
are bacteria certain medications and
genetics
if you have a mild case of acne your
doctor may recommend an over-the-counter
lotion
with one of several active ingredients
benzoyl peroxide kills bacteria
dries excess oil and removes dead skin
cells clogging pores
salicylic acid slows the loss of skin
cells
to prevent clogged pores it may also
break down whiteheads and blackheads
alpha hydroxy acids such as lactic acid
help remove dead skin cells
reduce inflammation and stimulate the
growth
of new smoother skin sulfur removes dead
skin cells
and dries excess oil
these are strong chemicals that may
irritate your skin
follow the directions for use exactly
if over-the-counter products are not
effective your dermatologist may
prescribe
stronger prescription lotions such as
vitamin a which reduces the buildup of
dead skin cells in your pores
topical antibiotics which kill bacteria
on your skin
or a combination of benzoyl peroxide and
topical antibiotics
for moderate to severe cases your
dermatologist
may prescribe an oral medication alone
or in combination with a topical
treatment
these medications include oral
antibiotics
which kill bacteria and reduce
inflammation
and isotretinoin which is used only for
the most
severe cases a corticosteroid injection
may be given to relieve your pain and
help clear up
a particularly large lesion for women
birth control pills containing estrogen
may be prescribed to minimize the
effects of testosterone
regardless of the treatment your doctor
recommends good skin care is essential
for example wash problem areas twice
daily with a mild soap and wash gently
without scrubbing if you have dry or
peeling skin
use an oil-free water-based moisturizer
when choosing any product to put on your
skin look for an oil-free
or non-comedogenic label which means it
won't clog your pores
avoid picking or squeezing blemishes as
these actions may lead to infection
or scarring and avoid touching your face
with your hands
your hair or any object such as a cell
phone